then most most Republicans according to
polls most independents they liked the
president State of the Union address a
few nights ago we were there covering
that I know you are too or I know you
you watched the speech joy read who's a
host over at MSNBC this is what she
tweeted about it she said church family
police military the national anthem
Trump trying to call on all the tropes
of 1950s era nationalism the goal of
this speech appears to be to force the
normal and as normalization of Trump on
the terms of the bygone era his
supporters are nostalgic for hashtag
State of the Union what's your opinion I
mean it's pretty amazing that the art of
politics always used to be getting your
opponents to actually oppose motherhood
apple pie in the American flag and now
Democrats are just embracing that too I
read is basically saying motherhood a
terrible apple pie terrible the American
flag terrible this is not about 1950s
America this is about a gap that has
been created by the hard left in the
United States which opposes all of these
unifying institutions and that was what
was truly amazing about the State of the
Union is that the president I thought
did a good job and this is why the the
polls reflected how popular the State of
the Union was he did a good job of
mentioning a lot of things that unify
Americans I'm running them things like
the police and the military and the
national anthem and the flag and
Democrats were sitting for those things
or two riding that I mean good luck in
2018 if that's your strategy well one
thing that unites America is the word
America and apparently the ACLU
complained that the president used the
word America a gigantic number
they said this tonight President Trump
said the word America more than 80 times
in his speech yet after a divisive first
year we hear and feel how exclusionary
that America is with policies that have
harmed so many vulnerable American
communities there they're using it
the ACLU actually Americans the first
letter in their acronym stands ready to
protect these communities both in the
courts and at the polls so do they have
a point no the American Civil Liberties
Union order they can call themselves the
international civil Civil Liberties
Union they only exist in the United
States because of American liberties
American freedoms the American
Constitution
they are to write it so this is totally
nuts I mean if you are so anti the word
America because it's so exclusive why
don't you just give up the title
American right you should not be
considering yourself an American it's
too exclusionary maybe you should be a
world citizen and with all the
privileges that entails
alright now lastly ban just to sum up
well here ones now in the books the
president laid out what he wants for
year two in November has this thing
gonna play out do you think and how was
it gonna affect the midterms I mean a
lot of it is going to depend on if the
president that we saw during the State
of the Union is the president that we
see for the rest of the year I thought
that he did an excellent job in the
State of the Union he really laid forth
the story that he wanted to tell I think
we're also gonna have to see what his
agenda is he talks a lot more about what
he did in 2017 than what they intend on
doing in 2018 and of course Democrats
are going to be highly intransigent the
good news is that the president's
greatest ally in Republican victory is
Chuck Schumer and Democrats who
apparently are incompetent in nearly
everything so you can at least take a
little bit of hope if you're a
Republican on the idea the Democrats may
blow this thing just as they've blown
everything else over the last couple of
years our local ultimately the greatest
thing that impacts the most people is
your money and with the wall withholding
charts and forms changing today people
are gonna have more money in their
pocket going forward because of the tax
cut Ben yeah absolutely I mean I
certainly well I'm in California I may
not see more money in my pocket
California is a terrible state but yeah
there's no question that if the impact
of the tax cut continues to be felt this
year I mean you can see the ballot the
generic ballots closing there's a
Monmouth poll yesterday showing that the
generic ballot gap is down to just D
plus 2 is 3 plus 15 a month ago so
clearly something has changed